disturbing new footage of the crime
crisis in democrat-led cities there's a
viewer warning here it's very tough to
watch this a man seen beating a
60-year-old woman inside a New York City
subway station for over two minutes Kane
actually broke
the suspect hitting her with her own
cane 60 times police sources say that
the woman did not know the suspect and
that the attacker had at least nine
prior arrests that's according to the
NYPD
EMS transported the victim in stable
condition the subject fled the location
departs unknown there are no arrests and
the investigation remains ongoing things
aren't better in Philadelphia the city's
police chief Danielle Outlaw will be
resigning as critics point out how
homicides Rose under her watch quote
over the course of her tenure annual
homicides in Philly Rose from 499 in
2020 to 516. in 2022 before Outlaw's
arrival between 2007 and 2019 murders in
the city range between 246 and 391 per
year
perhaps in her defense the prosecutors
aren't actually doing the job so they're
not putting people away and that
wouldn't be her fault there's also a new
mayor coming in but we'll talk about
that in a moment judge the crime on the
subway is so hard to watch and I think
though it's important for us to see it
so that we can actually name it and try
to at least say it's unacceptable
and what will they do about it well I
mean look it's the same thing we should
get used to this kind of thing it's it's
defining deviancy down this is like a
normal day on the subway now apparently
uh Eric Adams and the governor in
October pledged to have 1200 additional
uh overtime hours on the subway the
problem is as this woman is getting
beaten there's no one there there's no
one there to stop it and at the end
finally you see somebody of someone who
works for the subway system Metro the
subway system kind of come into the
picture but I understand that they know
who this guy is now it just happened
within a little bit he's got nine priors
trespassed uh resisting arrest assault
drugs etc etc this is never going to
change this is not going to change until
we change the bail laws and this whole
concept of social justice whatever the
heck it means which means nothing to all
of the victims who've been penalized is
is just it's creating a system where
there's total Anarchy and chaos and
there's no accountability now this woman
who was the uh police commissioner in
Chicago in Philadelphia do you know what
she is now they are moving her to be the
deputy chief security officer over
um airports Bridges tunnels
Transportation infrastructure for Port
Authority that is very important right
now and that it's a Peter Principle I
mean she does a bad job I mean you could
say maybe the prosecutors aren't
Prosecuting I mean it's a good point but
at the same time she should have been
yelling like a crazy woman that they
weren't but in the end until we
recognize that nothing's going to change
that until we change the laws then we're
all going to be victims and Jessica
she's a black woman uh there was the
black woman Police Commissioner in New
York City there was the one in Seattle
all of them do not feel supported enough
to continue on with their job so they're
walking away from them that actually I'm
surprised that there aren't more is it
more outcry about that especially from
the left interesting yeah I I think it's
awful and I did when I read what she was
going on to I said well that seems like
a promotion of some kind or a job that
it's a desk job versus a police
commissioner
that's out there having to face this on
a day-to-day basis in a different way
and
perhaps I want to minimize it I guess
maybe she's not going to be sitting
behind a desk but it did seem like a
cushy job to be going to if you had
overseen such a huge spike in these
murder rates
um I think it's awful the woman who was
beaten the subway her daughter was
interviewed about this and saying you
know how did no one help like the odds
are this wasn't a subway station that no
one goes to
um how could no one have stopped this
and she was standing there waiting to
the daughter was hosting a party that
she was late for saying like where's my
mom where's my mom and that's your worst
nightmare that this is what's going on
um and I think that it would be really
interesting if you could do one of these
like snapshots in time where you could
redo an election with these DA's right
and say now you've seen everything
that's happened it doesn't change your
politics right we all know that
Democrats are Democrats but
krasner or Greg brag what are you guess
call in La I know chassis Boudin was
recalled and it seems like uh they're
talking a little different about these
things Jesse Waters what's on your mind
I want to know who's filming these
assaults is there like a sick voyeurism
that's taken hold of the country they
sell it to the post and then they run
off with the cash why isn't someone just
dropping their phone and stopping the
beat down
you we just watched these videos over
and over again show after show and no
one ever tells people to knock it off
maybe it's the penny effect the Marine
that got I indicted what second degree
homicide for trying to stop something
like this from happening black women are
a sacred part of the Democrat voting
coalition yet a black woman is for two
minutes assaulted with a cane in a New
York City subway and fox is the only
Network covering it
the white house isn't commenting it if
this guy had a Maga head on they'd
binder would be going off but something
sick is happening where they only cover
political violence or racial violence
which is about one percent of the
violence this all of this stuff what
we're seeing right now is because of
academics that's where the D
incarceration movement started defund
bail reform these loony ideas that were
just theoretical because if the criminal
justice system is racist then you tear
down the criminal justice system and end
racism well look what happened has it
ended racism no it's exploded
criminality so we're just waiting around
for everybody to discredit this garbage
and the politicians to step up and stop
it but they're not that is interesting
that we're the only ones covering that
you know what it is I was thinking I was
thinking if uh if Rome
um if Rome had Fox News it's during the
decline this is exactly how it would
sound because what does what is the
decline like like clearly in the decline
of Rome people were watching it happen
and maybe they thought it's the it's the
slowly boiling frog and you just don't
know you're dead until you're dead but
we have leaders watching these Slow
Rolling disasters unfold and we keep
thinking there has to be a bottom here
where is the bottom when when are these
people like craftsner suddenly this is
too much for me this is disgusting but
there is no bottom and you wonder why
and you have these you have again
nobody's doing anything because they
believe the goal is the process so they
wanted to get more people out of prison
they just opened the doors and so you
end up with a guy with nine priors we
don't want to put them in because part
of the goal is reduced prison population
and we don't have a process for that so
we're just going to let out these free
range Maniacs because that's what they
are we are the public we're the general
public people are gonna I mean we know
people are leaving there's nothing we
can do you can't say we need more social
services or more uh affordable housing
we really need affordable housing
because all of these people are homeless
Dana but then do you ever see where
they're squatting and how they treat the
places they're squatting it's not about
affordable housing they are unfit to
take care of anything things get
destroyed in their control what should
we do with them well in that case you
put them away and you put them away for
years and if they're mentally ill
institutionalized to the hilt the
problem is nobody's going to do that
because we're we are too terrified of
discipline we're too terrified of
judgment we're too terrified of morality
and so we're scared into a corner by a
bunch of activists it's disgusting and
lawyers yeah no and Jesse's hair piece
stop I mean that one is pretty bad I
gotta say hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else